[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this of course is a segment
where viewers uh try to find mistakes on
our show and we've got terrific fans
that watch this show with an eagle eye
yeah they look really hard to find a
mistake so far there have been a lot of
challengers no winners nobody's caught
us making a mistake as far as we know we
haven't made one have it as far as we
know it's impossible
well tonight a fan named richard sheehan
from acton california thinks he caught a
mistake he claims that during a recent
comedy bit i got the name of a certain
dinosaur wrong
hey conan i'm watching your show right
now actually
and it's tuesday july 17th and you made
a joke about larry king
at brontesaurus funerals unlike me i
hope my kids won't have to larry king
wrote speak at countless brontosaurus
funerals
well i hate to break it to you but what
paleontologists once thought was a
brontosaurus is actually an apatosaurus
with the head of a camarosaurus
sorry conan
who are we booing here
okay
richard that guy thank you
someone spoke up that guy
one person spoke for the whole audience
i love that that is an organized crowd
the results are in conan it was that guy
is he
uh
well quick question this is my first
question for richard why are you living
in your high school gym just curious i
don't know what's going on there
that's right he's a janitor maybe he's
the janitor there now he lives at the
school but we should address his problem
i studied this and sorry richard but you
are dead wrong the name brontosaurus
actually predates the names apatosaurus
and camarasaurus and i have indisputable
proof
check it out
hey richard from acton california you
are wrong and i should know i am the one
who named that dinosaur
and i named it brontosaurus for my
caveman friend bronto
who had just gotten stepped on by it
so richard you're wrong
nice
so the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
reported
teamcoco.com i found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chump meat
out of the maestro
and if i may a quick thanks to larry
king for helping us out be sure to check
out his new show larry king now on hulu
yes and
could someone please show larry king how
to use hulu
[Music]
we'll take a break